لن نقبل الا بنصف بولندا مقابل جندي روسي
واحد هكذا اعلنت تاموسكو وربما تضع حجر
عثره امام انضمام اوكرانيا للقاره العجوز
واوكرانيا تمطر الاراضي الروسيه بالصواريخ
لساعات المتواصله فكيف سترد موسكو وتحرك
روسي مريب يثير مخاوف النيتو والزلني يضع
حلفائه الامريكيين في موقف محرج واكبر
محطه نوويه في اوكرانيا واوروبا تقرع
اجراس الخطر والوكاله الدوليه تتحرك بشكل
عاجل وبكين لا ترقص لكل من يغني لكم
اتفاقات السلام والهذونات لا تجدي نفعا مع
السودانيين وصياط العقوبات الاوروبيه تجلد
ايران مجددا
طعنه في ظهر اوكرانيا
ضربه من هنا واخرى من هناك داخليا وخارجيا
تتلقى اوكرانيا الضربات لكن ضربات
الاصدقاء اشد ايلاما هنا وزير الخارجيه
النمساويه
لا يمكن قبول اوكرانيا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قبل دول البلقان لم يكتفي بذلك
ليضع الملح على جروح الاوكران قائلا انه
يجب على الغرب ان يواصل التفاوض مع روسيا
لانها اكبر جار جغرافي للاتحاد الاوروبي
واكبر قوه نوويه على هذا الكوكب وكانه
يقول دعوكم من اوكرانيا وتتفاوض مع روسيا
وستنجي ادخنه كل هذه الحروف لينضم رئيس
البرلمان الجورجي شلفا لشمبرج محذرا من ان
التطبيق بلاده نظام التاشيرات للروس
سيستدعي اجراءات جوابيه روسيا وسيلحق
اضرارا جسيمه باقتصاد جورجيا وامنها اي ان
الجورجيين لا يريدون اي عداوه مع روسيا
مهلا مهلا مهلا فالامر لم ينتهي بعده
لياتي الدور على وزير الدفاع الهنجاري
الذي قال ان اصرار الدول الاوروبيه على
تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يهدد امنها الخاص
ومخزونات الاستراتيجيه ويقصد ان امن
اوروبا في خطر دائم طالما يواصل
الاوروبيون دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا تاتي كل
تلك الضربات لكيه بينما تحضر قواتها
لهجومها المضاد ومع اقتراب اندلاع ذلك
الهجوم والذي سيشمل زبروج يا الهي لقد
اصبتم راسي بصداع بهذه الكلمه الهجوم
المضاد الهجوم المضاد الهجوم المضاد متى
سينفذ هذا الهجوم لنكمل حيث يتبادل الرؤوس
والاوكران الاتهامات بضرب النوويه هذه
المعارك جعلت مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رضا
يتحرك ليطرح صفقه امام مجلس الامن الدولي
هذا الشهر لاتفاق بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بهدف حمايه محطه
للطاقه النبويه فهل يتفق الطرفان على
تجنيب زبروج نيران المعارك وتعد محطه التي
تقع جنوبيه اوكرانيا اكبر محطه نوويه في
هذا البلد واوروبا عموما وتسيطر علي
القوات الروسيه منذ الاشهر الاولى من
الحرب اي ان اي تسريب للاشعاع قد تصل
اضراره للقاره العجوز باكملها هنا تشدنا
اصوات الرصاص وزنجره المدافع نعم انها
بخمه حيث تقول الدفاع الاوكراني ان قوتها
تتقدم على اطراف مدينه باكموت لمحاصره
القوات الروسيه مؤكده وجود القوات
الاوكرانيه داخل اذا فماذا عن اعلام موسكو
السيطره على بالكامل ليعلنها مستشار
البنتاجون السابق دوجلاس ماغريغور بقوله
ان محاوله الرئيس الاوكراني
عادت على بعواقب وخيمه وخساره المدينه
ليعيد
فخسر المدينه وخسر المعركه وفق التعبير
وعلى الارض ايضا اعلن الجيش الاوكراني
تعرض مدينه دينيبرو لهجوم روسي بسته عشر
صاروخا وعشرين طائره مسيره واكدت السلطات
الاوكرانيه اسقاط خمسه عشره طائره مسيره
واربعه صواريخ كروز كانت تستهدف المدينه
بما اعلن المتحدث باسم قوات الدفاع
الاوكراني في خرسون تمكن الجيش الاوكراني
من اسقاط مقاتله من نوع سو خمسه وثلاثين
خلال تحليقها فوق المدينه وبالعوده الى
الملف الس بين الغرب وروسيا تنتظر كييف
قرارا غربيا بتزويدها بمقاتلات اف 16
الامريكيه حيث اشار مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل
الى بحث ملف تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف
16 مؤكدا اننا تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على المقاتلات الامريكيه الصنع قد بدا
لياتي الرد الروسي فورا وعلى لسان نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سرجير الذي قال ان
اهداف العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ستتحقق على
الرغم من ضخ الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا وتدريب
طيارين اوكرانيين على مقاتله اف 16 بينما
اعتبر السفير الروسي لدى الولايات المتحده
ان اي هجوم اوكراني على شبه جزيره القرن
بطائرات اف 16 سيعد هجوما على الاراضي
الروسيه وهناك فلننتظر الرد الروسي الغاضب
يا ساده ليعود الاوكران ينقل المعارك الى
الاراضي الروسيه مجددا حيث افاد حاكم
مقاطعه
في المقاطعه المحاميه للحدود الاوكرانيه
تعرضت لقصف من جانب اوكرانيا على مدى
ساعات عده مضيفا ان مجموعه تخريبيه
اوكرانيه عبرت الحدود الى داخل اراضي
المقاطعه لكن قوات الامن بدات باتخاذ
اجراءات للتعامل مع المجموعه التخريبيه
وفق تعبيره فهل تحاول اوكرانيا توجيها
ضربات كهذه لروسيا لتمحو صوره الهزيمه في
بخموت وفي سياق اخر عاد الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي للظهور امام الصحفيين اثناء
حضوره قمه السبع ليقول ان صور الدمار في
هيروشيما تذكره بباخموت والتجمعات السكنيه
الاخرى المماثله مضيفا لم يبقى شيء على
قيد الحياه انهارت كل المباني ليضع حليفه
بايد موقف لا يحسد عليه خصوصا وان الرئيس
الامريكي رفض ان يعتذر عن كارثه هيروشيما
لكن تلك اللفه لم تمر مرور الكرام على
روسيا لتتلقفها سريعا صاحبه الردود الذيعه
والملقبه بالخاله فرنسا فرع روسيا قائله
للنسكي لا تنسى ان البيت الابيض رتب
الامرين اي ان امريكا هي من قصفت هيروشيما
بين نووي وهي من تسببت بدمار بخموت فيا له
من رد قوي من الخاله فرنسا فرع روسيا
ماريا الزخرفه عادت مره اخرى لتوجه حديثه
لبولندا هذه المره حيث ذكرت زخرف
المسؤولين البولنديين بمساهمه الاتحاد
السوفيتي بتحرير وارسو من النازيين واعاده
اعمار الدوله البولنديه بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لتقول اقترحوا ان نطالب
بنصف بولندا تعويضا عن واحده في اشاره
للفلاح ايفان سوسانين البطل القومي الروسي
الذي انقذ في عام
1613 الملك ميخائيل رومانوف من الموت على
يد الغزاه البولنديين
الاحداث والتطورات قالت السفاره الصينيه
في لندن انه يجب على السلطات البريطانيه
التركيز على مشاكلها الخاصه وليس الرقص
على انغام الولايات المتحده بينما كان
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني قد قال في قمه
مجموعه السبع في هيروشيما ان الصين تمثل
التحدي الاكبر في عصرنا للامن والازدهار
العالميين في السودان وقعت اشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
محيط القصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم وذلك
قبيل ساعات من دخول وقف اطلاق النار
الموقع بين الاطراف في جده حيز التنفيذ
اعلنا مفوض سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل تبني الحزمه الثامنه
من العقوبات ضد ايران على خلفيه انتهاكات
حقوق الانسان هل بدا الاوروبيون يميلون
لروسيا بعيدا عن الاملاءات الامريكيه ما
الذي ترونه انتم متابعينا
[موسيقى]